mobilisation exceptionnelle pour
l'emploi c'est le principe de cette
plateforme lancée par le gouvernement
objectif permettre de faciliter le
recrutement dans les filières
nécessaires à la lutte contre le coc vie
de dix neuf avec pôle emploi en première
ligne aujourd'hui nous nous concentrons
beaucoup de moyens sur les offres
concernant les secteurs essentiels en
contact avec les entreprises les
conseillers pôle emploi répertorie les
offres et accompagne la démarche de
recrutement tout demandeur d'emploi ou
travailleurs en chômage partiel peut
ensuite postuler sur cette plateforme
qui si nous avons les secteurs dits donc
prioritaire par rapport à la situation
donc où nous allons pouvoir déposer les
offres des employeurs en difficultés de
recrutement voilà ça va nous aider je
l'espère à trouver des candidats
donc ça touche voilà le des postes
d'agents de service hospitalier dans la
grande distribution auxiliaires de vie
aides soignants c'est ça peut être des
vacations d'une heure à 10 heures selon
la structure n'a vraiment besoin de tout
le personnel possible nos structures
d'aidé à domicile sont vraiment en
difficulté puisque
des personnes dépendantes ont besoin
encore ont besoin qu'on se rende chez
elle pour des ados repas pris au
médicament aux toilettes
actuellement 115 offres d'emploi sont
proposées sur la plateforme dans le
département des yvelines